your tongle me page is a great way to
share your availability with others and
let them schedule meetings with you
here's how to edit your availability on
your public
page first sign into your tongling
account and make sure you're on home in
the top
menu next we'll click the availability
icon in the left
sidebar click
availability and you'll see your weekly
calendar view the orange boxes show the
times that you you've made available on
your tongle me page the Whit space is
where you're not
available I've set my availability for
mornings and afternoons I don't like to
have late meetings on Friday so I've set
my afternoons for 1: to
4:30 let's say I don't want to meet
people on Friday at all all I have to do
is erase the Times by clicking and
dragging on the calendar
view if I decide that I actually want to
meet with people on Friday mornings
I can paint back over the calendar view
to make myself
available once I'm
done I click
save then I can visit my tongel me page
in public
profile now I can see that I'm no longer
available on Friday afternoons but I am
in the
mornings now let's say next Friday I do
want to meet people in the afternoon but
it'll only be for that day and I don't
want it duplicated across all
weeks I go back to
home select the availability icon
again and this time I select
exceptions I scroll to the week I want
to
edit and I paint in the
exception a green box shows that I've
made this time avail
aable if I want to make a previously
available time not available I paint
over that as well and a red box shows me
I've made that
busy now once again this is just a daily
exception and won't be duplicated across
all
weeks I click
save and then I can visit public profile
to see my
changes I scroll to the week
and I can see that I've made myself
available on Friday afternoon but not
Thursday
afternoon by scrolling through my other
weeks I can see that my weekly
availability is still the same as it was
before and that's how you edit
availability in tungle me